i just think too like with that versus i
was telling everybody before it happened
i was like man the one thing people are
not factoring into this battle is
the locks still actually [ __ ] with each
other they're still actually chemistry
chemistry camaraderie chemistry these
guys are still with each other my man
right there reem scully's hurt hurt he
thought
he still hurt
he'd been on twitter saying that he
wanted to do a rematch on live and the
songs that they match he's hurt you know
a lot of people were hurt by that
you know what though
hello x baby
did i say something my problem is this
it's a lot of people that's acting like
they don't know
already
now people people but
now but you know what the difference is
now is
now listen the difference is kiss
this verses has done something that no
other verses really has done and i feel
like now
i was on academic [ __ ] right now and
they just posted a kiss verse he did
with dream doll and said is this the
verse of the year i'm like that [ __ ]
ain't happening you know now like the
younger kids who might not have known
the pedigree that jadakiss when they did
that [ __ ]
yo man but y'all ain't got nothing for
them females
oh man it was a murder and when when
kiss came back with the female bag oh my
god they did the jenny from the block
and the mura i said
this this is embarrassing at this point
we got grims
y'all got grams
and then they i forget what shouts to
shouts to jones though
listen i love dipset and like on the
surface i can see
how you could be like i got dipset
winning the battle before it happened
but once you really start thinking like
man
jaina was on i mean the locks were on
you know life after death they were on
it's dark and hell is hot you know what
i'm saying like this is different it's a
different bag it's just a whole
different bag there to watch g unit
i think so
i think so
it's undebatable
yeah and it would have been nice unit
would have been fired yeah
but the thing is is that camaraderie but
then i don't know like you could like
50 is tough to wash but long he don't
need g unit 50 just needs to stand on
stage and talk
50 could just play get rich or die
trying from front to back
and just have the mic and just troll
people that's the one thing i would love
to see jada and 50 on stage just just
just throwing shots at each other
because they were both hilarious
type [ __ ]
but i was like i was so disappointed
with cab i was expecting cab to say some
funny [ __ ] i was like man anytime jim
jones was performing his [ __ ] cameron
was in the back with like the aunt i was
like damn
styles was with kids like they were with
each other that [ __ ] was historical
though
we gotta